princess diana a tribute exhibition is
officially open at the shops at crystals
coinciding with the 25th anniversary of
her passing jillian takes us inside for
a sneak peek of the interactive
experience
well princess diana a tribute exhibition
is officially open here at the shops at
crystal and it is absolutely beautiful
we are inside with the curator himself
david thanks for having us thanks for
coming incredible all right it has been
a long time in the making and it's so
great to see it all coming together so
right now we are in kind of like the
third room the big showcase as you enter
in through the exhibit and you might not
be able to tell where we are now but we
have to do the big reveal we're standing
on a glass floor and what are we
standing on we'll walk around and show
you a 25 foot train of diana's wedding
dress this is an artist installation
exclusively commissioned for this
exhibit
and
it's pretty striking believe it or not
this is actually completely fashioned
out of paper oh my gosh this is
absolutely incredible and just one of
the many things that you can see
throughout the exhibit and in this room
everything is interactive you get to
walk through tell us a little bit about
what else is in this room specifically
this room is completely dedicated to her
wedding to charles
whether it's the seating plan from the
private breakfast the morning before
that the queen and philip held or it is
bridesmaid items including the flowers
she actually walked down the hall the
aisle with uh or items from their
honeymoon so where did they actually go
where do a princess and a prince go on
honeymoon
and you can learn about all that in this
room there's probably over 50 items in
this room that are authentic from her
wedding
and yeah we just really can't wait to
have people coming in today and checking
it out oh everyone is going to love it
and let's talk about those artifacts and
these items that are found throughout
where did they come from how did you
collect everything so we partnered with
the group the pink ribbons crusade
they've been working the last 45 years
to carry this collection and they they
lend out that collection in support of
their cause breast cancer so a portion
of the proceeds from each ticket sold
will be donated to fight breast cancer
wow that is incredible and it's a lot
more than just an exhibit in here
there's so much to learn and why do you
think after all this time even princess
diana still remains an icon to even us
here in the states
she was an icon because i think her her
influence is actually growing more and
more with time
her compassion for others her love of
family
the way she actually changed the world
with humanitarian efforts those are
values that are still so relevant today
maybe even more so such a role model
that she is is one of the most
significant people of our time
well david thank you for creating such a
beautiful exhibit for everyone to take
in i am so excited for everybody out
here in las vegas to see it and there's
so much more to explore so i'll have to
continue making our way through but i'm
really really excited people are going
to love it i think they will i can't
wait for them to all come see it thank
you david thank you
wow
yeah